un
moment de joie pour cette famille un peu
de répit pour oublier la tante de
l'appel tant espéré qu'ils leur
annoncera que le petit xavier pourra
enfin se faire opérer le garçon de 4 ans
est épileptique seul une chirurgie peut
stopper pour de bon ces crises et pour
xavier le temps presse alors qu'à chaque
fois qu'il a une crise d'épilepsie
ça continue d'agrandir et de tués de
plus en plus de son neuro chirurgie
veulent opérer depuis un mois le médecin
est disponible mais est possible en ce
moment de trouver des infirmières pour
l'assister une conséquence directe du
nombre record de spécialisation liés à
la queue vite dans la province il n'y a
pas assez de personnes pour prendre soin
de lui non seulement dans le moment de
deux chaufferies mais aussi la presse
parce que ça va prendre à peu près
à l'hôpital famille mais tu es loin
d'être la seule dans cette situation en
alberta partout dans la province si la
vie de patients des pommes menacés dans
les trois prochains jours la chirurgie
est reporté services de santé alberta
confirme que depuis deux semaines 75 %
de toutes les chirurgies dans la
province ont été remises à plus tard
même des chirurgies pour le cancer ou
encore pour les enfants sont repoussés
impossible de savoir exactement combien
d'interventions déjà été annulés mais la
province confirme que des milliers
d'entre elles devront être reprises
c'est une décision extrêmement difficile
à prendre et nous sommes profondément
désolés pour tous les patients et leurs
familles les patients touchés seront
contactés par services de santé alberta
et créer un porte parole face à la crise
plusieurs associations médicales demande
au gouvernement de réimposer confinement
et des mesures sanitaires plus strictes
pour réduire la pression sur les
hôpitaux un pas de plus que ne veut pas
faire le premier ministre pour l'instant
nous attendons à voir les résultats des
mesures que nous avons prises la semaine
dernière
chez les messieurs on a du mal à
accepter que l'alberta et pu se rendre
jusque là alors que d'autres provinces
ont su mieux contenir la quatrième vague
françois suivante à ce que je trouve que
notre gouvernement ait enfin un
vrai travail de gérer tout ça le maire
du xvi et lors les algues vertes et qui
n'ont pas fait aller se faire vacciner
pour soulager le système de santé la
famille mathieu elle est condamnée à
attendre
on veut juste que l'homme
puisse avoir une vie normale
j'espère qu'ils puissent un jour
conduire et water
il va finir l'école
mais de ce qu'il nous explique c'est que
s'ils écrivent contenu
il va perdre
pour eux et des milliers d'autres chaque
journée qui passe en est une de trop ici
mathieu gaye radio canada calgary